the bell foundry since the Middle Ages
in our territory
in Italy there were many
unfortunately today we are a bit
few
[Music] I
am pasquale marinelli my family
makes a living from the year one thousand it is a work
of the Middle Ages and today we
still work  how we worked in the Middle Ages
[Music]
my brother armando and I should
be the 26th generation that
continues to make bells first spread
a bell we know all the parameters and above all we
save the note is the voice
that a bell will emit from the
bell tower
each note corresponds to  a diameter of
a bell anywhere in the world they
heard our bell recognizes the
easy thing so it will have a particular sound it
is very recognizable
when we cast the bells there
is so much of ours there is so much of
our work we can give  a soul
to the bell
one of our most important customers
naturally
the most beautiful moment of my life
when john with  the second
entered this madness
for all the ancestors who look at us
simple I can confirm that what
was
most beautiful of our business is
an art that you carry inside and that you must
then pass on to those who come after you
I hope my children  are passionate
in the same way
[Music]